hello everyone welcome back to the
channel I hope you all had a good
Memorial Day weekend um if you want to
hear about something that's a little bit
more unamerican we can talk about Delta
Airlines deciding to shaft me from
behind and delaying my flight such that
I had to move it to tomorrow so uh while
I had successfully made a good
procrastination plan to record this
thing tomorrow uh now I'm going to have
to go ahead and do it tonight and thly I
am burning the midnight oil here at
11:00 p.m. after waking up at 5:30 this
morning so I'm going to make a lot of
mistakes in this video but nonetheless
we're going to do it and I'm going to do
it live so let's go ahead and talk about
Twitch TV all right let's go ahead and
get into it for those of you who live
under a rock twitch is a live streaming
site where you can go ahead and post
content as a streamer and then other
people can watch your live stream cool
so for example here is the name of a
video that I might be doing on Twitch
sometime soon obviously it's going to
have at least 100,000 people watching
because uh this is a subject that a lot
of people care ad about and then we've
also got a chat over here on the side
and uh users can both read other
people's messages and they can also send
messages cool let's move on to some
formal problem requirements for starters
basically if I'm a streamer I need to be
able to stream you need to be able to
watch my streams secondly uh viewers who
are actually watching streams should be
able to basically adaptively uh change
the quality of their stream to support
their Network bandwidth so if I'm
walking on my phone outdoors and I'm
trying to watch some sort of twitch
stream stream uh basically I want to be
sure that uh my Kina cop stream is first
coming in at 1080P and maybe if uh my
internet gets a little bit worse it goes
down to
720p cool number three is that we want
to basically be able to record these
streams and play them back later that is
simple enough number four like I
mentioned in the last slide we've got
chat cool so the gist is streams can
have hundreds of thousands of viewers uh
it definitely does happen in real life I
recall back in the fortnite days or the
Golden Days uh Drake hopped on a few few
times to a stream and streamed with
Ninja and there were definitely that
many people so it can happen you can
even have millions of people so it
really is popular cool the first thing
that we're going to be talking about is
networking so if you've been a good boy
or a good girl and have watched
basically all of these videos in order
uh you might be thinking about our Zoom
video from last time if you haven't
screw you anyways no just kidding in our
Zoom video we used UDP right as opposed
to TCP for a couple of reasons the first
being that UD p is typically faster
there's less overhead to sending all of
these packets and we're not really doing
anything for congestion control and flow
control uh additionally with video
chatting um if I miss a frame on your
end I no longer care about it I would
just rather see it as a dropped frame or
maybe a lag Spike for a second on my
screen because you know you showing that
frame to me retroactively isn't going to
make any sense with streaming it's maybe
going to be a little bit different the
thing to note is that with something
like twitch we really want to have high
quality streams right A lot of people do
care they say oh you know if this guy's
playing his video game in 4k and I have
a 4k monitor it would be really really
awesome if assuming I have the network
uh capacity to do so I could also watch
it in similar
quality and so the one thing to note is
if I'm a streamer and I'm sending my
stream out to all these other viewers if
I'm doing so instantly right if I'm just
instantly saying hey the second I play
this on my computer as fast as possible
I want you to see it then sure it's the
same situation as a video chat and any
dropped frames you wouldn't care about
how however what twitch will do or what
other streaming sites will do is they'll
actually add a small delay to all of
these streams and they'll add a few
different seconds the reason being that
if I'm watching this I'm not really
going to notice a few seconds it's not
like I'm actively interacting with you
and if I am I'm probably not watching
your stream maybe the chat is going to
be delayed you know 5 10 seconds but at
the end of the day that's not really a
huge deal and so because of this delay
now actually if I understand that I'm
the streamer and I've dropped a few
packets trying to send them to you I
actually have time to go ahead and
resend those so that you can get them
back in time and basically recreate uh
my full video stream without having to
drop any frames and so what this means
is that rather than having to use UDP we
should probably be using TCP which is
going to resend all those drw packets
and resend them in order cool and so
this is going to be the premise behind
something known as rtmp or realtime
message protocol I think that for the
sake of a systems design interview you
probably wouldn't be expected to know
this term and so I'm not really going to
to go into all the nitty-gritty details
of uh this framework for starters
because I don't know them but second of
all I think that uh we should just break
this problem down from first principles
and then go from there and we should
probably end up coming up with something
similar to it
anyways cool so the first thing that
we're going to be talking about is data
chunking right we have all of this video
footage how do we actually want to go
ahead and send it out to clients so um
pretty much in all of our videos in the
past where we're handling uh video data
uh the Youtube videos the Netflix uh
video anything like that typically we
want to be performing some sort of
chunking right and to be fair that's not
the case for Zoom but we'll talk about
why it helps us here for starters if we
had to send a single message per frame
to all of our clients uh that would be a
lot of messages both for us to publish
and for them to consume and there would
be quite a bit of overhead there um so
again keep that in mind another thing is
that uh just because we're going to
eventually have to persist all of these
chunks or or frames data about those
frames as metadata somewhere uh this is
going to mean that we now have fewer
rows there to persist right if I had to
persist every single frame and we're
streaming at 60 frames per second now
every single second I'm having to add 60
rows to my database and that could be
pretty expensive as well um the reason
that we need metadata tables are for a
couple of things for one uh we mentioned
that we wanted to be able to uh watch
back these streams later and if we're
doing that we're going to have to be
able to basically you know take some
sort of video uh file and S3 and have
some metadata that links us to it and
then another thing is that we also want
to be able to align the timestamps of
chunks of different resolutions so I'm
going to talk about this more in the
next slide but the gist is imagine I'm a
slow client and uh you know my network
speed all of a sudden becomes much worse
I want to basically now start reading uh
at the next chunk but at a lower
resolution so again I'll cover that in a
second if you're a little bit confused
there so the big thing here is that we
also don't want to make our chunks too
big right if we make our chunks too
small all of a sudden we have uh too
many messages to send if we make our
chunks too big and for whatever reason
one chunk doesn't make it to a client
now having to resend that chunk is going
to be a pretty expensive operation so we
want to get a good balance between too
small and too big of a chunk size at
least from my understanding in reality
it's like a second of video footage but
of course you know if you're building
out a site like this yourself you're
going to have to experiment quite a bit
cool the next piece that I'm going to
talk about is what I just be mentioning
which is aligning chunks for slow
clients so like I mentioned as our
clients uh networking capabilities
change we want to basically be able to
change the resolution of the stream to
account for this so we did the same
exact thing when building YouTube in our
prior video so hopefully uh you're
familiar with it to some extent but for
those of you who did not watch that the
gist is like this let's imagine that we
want to be able to support three
different resolutions for our stream 480
720 and 1080p additionally we have all
of these time stamps right this is chunk
one this is chunk two chunk three and
chunk four so if they're a second long
that means 1 second into the stream two
seconds 3 seconds and four seconds so
basically we want to keep some sort of
metadata table or create one that
actually aligns all of these things the
reason being let's say that I start out
right and uh my network is super fast so
I begin by consuming this stream at
1080p you know I'm continuing to have
good networking speeds and so I watch
the next chunk at 1080p I go to my metad
meta data table and say hey get me uh
the S3 URL for that next chunk all of a
sudden uh my client gets a little bit
slower right and we notice that the
packets are taking a little bit longer
to come in so now all of a sudden what
we're going to do is start fetching uh
chunks at a lower resolution oh now
we're going to try 720 oh shoot you know
what this took a little bit longer than
we were hoping let's actually move
ourselves all the way over to 480p and
note how when we align all of the chunks
like this it means that we're not going
to a drop any frames or B repeat any
frames we're actually getting a like
perfectly sliced together video which is
really nice so that is the reason that
we want to be using standardized chunk
sizes and it also means that uh it's
going to give the client a much better
experience compared to you know dropping
frames and or getting duplicate
frames cool the next thing that I want
to actually talk about is delivering our
video to viewers so thus far I've just
kind of described this abstractly right
we understand that video is starting out
on the streamer PC and it's going to end
up on client devices in one way or
another the question is should we be
having those two connect directly and my
answer would be probably not this is
because of a couple of reasons the first
is that there can be lots of viewers
right I mentioned there can literally be
hundreds of thousands of viewers for
these streams if I'm a streamer PC if
I'm just you know streaming off my
little gaming PC at home having 100,000
people hitting that all at once that's
not going to go well additionally even
if we were just say streaming to five
different people uh we want to be
minimizing the load on my PC because I'm
playing a video game for those of you
who are PC Gamers you know this can be
intensive stuff especially if I'm
playing at a high resolution and at the
end of the day I want to save as much uh
Power on my computer as possible to
actually get a higher frame rate in my
game and devote less so to actually
having to stream that game so that's an
important thing to note some streamers
will actually even offload uh the
capturing of the footage and sending it
to Twitch onto a completely different
computer but even still you don't want
to overload the computer cool so the
gist here is well okay if um it's not
the computer itself that's doing the
streaming that's going to basically
publish this footage to clients then
perhaps we're going to have to introduce
some sort of intermediary server so I'm
going to call this guy the streaming
server and we'll talk about this a
little bit more in a second but the
first thing to note is that if you
recall from our previous slide we're
going to only be publishing footage or
we're only going to be playing the video
game in one resolution but we're going
to need to be able to have multiple
different resolutions of the footage
available so what's actually going going
to be responsible for creating those
should it be the streamer PC well
probably not because that is going to
take a lot of extra effort on the part
of the streamer and that we don't really
want to deal with that being said uh
what we do want to do is keep load as
low as possible on the streamer PC and
additionally keep in mind that in the
case of a live stream unlike Zoom only
one person is actually publishing
footage right in Zoom every single
person on the video call is publishing
footage and it has to be distributed to
all clients in this case we've only got
one streamer and so as a result it
becomes a lot more practical to do all
of this encoding server side so our
streaming server now is actually going
to basically take in the footage from
the streaming PC it's going to encode it
to a couple of different resolutions and
then it's going to push it out to all of
the interesting
clients the next thing I want to talk
about is actually making sure that this
stream server is going to be fall
tolerant and scalable uh to this point
we've just acted like there's one of
them and of course if we're going to
only have one of them it's going to be a
single point of failure so let's talk
about this a little bit more in depth
the first thing that I'll talk about is
partitioning basically one idea is say
oh you know based on my IP address I
should be connected to a certain uh chat
server well maybe that's not the best
idea because you know what if over a
given stream say I'm streaming on my
phone and then all of a sudden I switch
from Wi-Fi to my 5G now I no longer make
sense right like I'm going to start
going to a different streaming server
and then things are going to break down
um additionally uh it would be bad if I
were to just uh switch device during the
streaming session if I went from like my
PC to my PlayStation or something like
that so I think what we should
ultimately be doing is some sort of
consistent hashing but on the actual
stream ID hopefully that makes sense and
then the other thing that I want to talk
about is Fault tolerance or replication
well we have a couple of options as we
mentioned we're already going to
basically be partitioning our available
streaming servers uh based on the stream
ID and doing consistent hashing so
option one is just if a stream server
goes down basically offload all of the
streams that were connected to it and
you know evenly distribute them across
all the existing stream servers uh
that's just how consistent hashing works
so that's one option it's not a bad one
but do keep in mind that you run the
risk of actually overloading some of the
existing servers if too many of these
stream servers go down uh another
possible option is that we actually run
a bunch of passive stream servers which
basically sit there doing nothing
listening to zookeeper and then you know
this zookeeper says hey you're the
primary uh or basically hey your primary
actually went down they say oh sounds
good I'll be the primary now please
connect to me uh so this I think does
ultimately work a little bit better I
think that uh depending on what company
you are or if you're using you know like
a a cloud Solutions provider uh it might
incur some extra costs um but I do think
it has probably the least downside to
just use a passive
backup cool the next piece we're going
to talk about here is actually loading
stream faster or rather getting them to
clients faster so in our current setup
or at least how we've described things
so far we've got a streamer we're
publishing to some sort of server and
then the server is disseminating that
out to all of our
viewers so we're going to have problems
in a couple of situations here one is
going to be a stream with lots of users
because at the end of the day uh you can
publish to a lot of places um but if you
have to publish to 100,000 places you're
probably not going to be able to do that
well number two is streams with uh
geographically distributed viewers right
so if my stream is originating in the
United States but I also have someone
watching me in China someone watching me
in South Africa someone watching me in
Australia things are going to get slow
for those viewers so how are we going to
be able to handle these two
things well the answer is going to
always be cashing so as far as our
static content goes aka the video chunks
themselves that's where we care about
cdns cdns as we've described them in the
past are basically just Geographic Al
distributed caches uh that are really
good at handling static content so we
can actually put them all over the globe
additionally keep in mind that besides
just having to know about the static
content all of these viewers actually
have to be able to read the metadata as
well for each chunk and its offset and
so we can just use a normal cash or
something like Reddit for all of those
chunk metadata rows cool the next thing
is as you can see I've drawn the US
right here I absolutely put this guy
over here I know it's poorly drawn I
swear to God if you knit me in the
comments I'm going to going to have a
panic attack gist is if this guy's the
server right here it is getting the
information to all of these
geographically distributed caches and
then the users that are nearby those
caches can read from them
accordingly so now the question to ask
is well we have all of these caches how
should we be getting the data there
sorry I'm losing my voice it is
late how do we want to get the data to
these caches well basically we've got
two options we can push the data there
or we can pull the data into the cash
after an initial cash Miss so ideally it
would be great if we can always push the
data right because then you can avoid
that initial cash Miss and one unhappy
user who may have a slightly longer
loading time to get their stream going
at the same time is this always going to
be feasible let's examine that well for
starters if we want to be able to push
certain stream data to caches we
probably want to know in advance which
streams are worthy of being pushed to
caches and the answer to that is always
going to be the popular ones and the
question is well how do we know which
streams are going to be popular in
advance well maybe there are some cues
right certain streamers are verified and
tend to have bigger followings so that
probably does cover I would say like 95%
of cases where we have a popular stream
but occasionally if you are a twitch
user you'll know about things like
stream hosting or stream raids where
basically one popular streamer basically
gets all of their viewers to go jump on
to some other unpopular stream after
they sign off and so when that happens
what we could H have all of a sudden is
basically a massive group of viewers
that just jumped onto an unpopular
stream and a poll based caching setup
may not be able to handle that so well
so let's go ahead and check out
why well what could happen is it can
lead to a Thundering Herd so what would
this Thundering Herd look like like I
mentioned imagine we have some unpopular
streamer and now they have a lot of
viewers within this uh the span of a
couple of seconds so this is going to be
our un popular streamer over here this
is our encoding server that we've spoken
about which is already under fairly
heavy load because it's taking some you
know high definition stream and putting
it into multiple different resolutions
and sending it out to a few viewers now
let's imagine we have some empty cach
you're not empty but you know it doesn't
contain the data for this particular
stream now we also have a th000 viewers
that all of a sudden want data from that
cache so the first thing that's going to
happen is all of them at the same exact
time are going to hit the cach and the
cach is going to say I don't have data
all at once right because you know
they're literally all joining at like a
very similar time and the cash just has
not yet been populated when that happens
they're going to go ahead and all
basically hit the encoding server right
because when you don't have data in the
cache the cache has to go to the actual
source of the data which is either the
encoding server or maybe some database
that the encoding server is publishing
to and it's going to hit that place a
thousand times that's bad that's a
Thundering Herd what can we do to stop
this well basically it's not too
complicated but still worth talking
about we can use a lock right so in this
cache we're going to have a lock over
here the first request over here is
going to grab the lock which is
basically going to prohibit anyone else
from reaching out to the encoding server
and then all of these guys are going to
attempt to grab the lock but then when
they actually you know when this guy
finally releases the lock and then it's
time for say this guy to grab the lock
oops sorry when it's time for this guy
down here to grab the lock now the data
is going to be available and uh we don't
actually have to go to our encoding
server so this is going to stop us from
having thundering
herds cool the next aspect of this is
going to actually be how we can record
our streams so like I mentioned um it's
going to be very useful for us to be
able to take a previous stream and
actually watch it as if it were a
YouTube video and it's very simple to do
that right because we're already
publishing all of these small chunks of
data and then from there we just need to
basically be able to access all of that
metadata down the line and then from
there uh pull the actual chunks out of a
data store so what do we want to store
our chunks in well probably S3 it's just
a given we get pretty much infinite
storage or infinitely scalable storage
you're obviously going to have to pay
for it um but S3 is always going to be
very good for static content uh as far
as our actual metadata tell uh table
itself this is an interesting question
because one thing that we do want is to
make sure that we can quickly publish to
that table and we also be want to be
able to quickly read it and so at least
in my mind I think this is actually
going to be a very good use case for
hbas the reason being we can get
relative ly fast wrs from the LSM tree
LSM tree is obviously going to initially
write to an inmemory tree uh
additionally it is column oriented
storage meaning that um you know if we
only want the chunks for one particular
resolution at a time because a client uh
you know is pretty much hard stuck at
that resolution you can just read that
column as opposed to reading all of the
columns in the metadata row and then
finally just in terms of how we want to
actually set this thing up let's go
ahead and partition it by stream ID so
that when we're actually reading it we
only have to read from one partition and
sort by time stamp so that we can get a
nice clean range query and not have to
resort all of those rows on the client
side cool let us talk about stream chat
the last aspect of this video so unlike
Facebook Messenger right where you can
be in multiple different chats at once
the easy thing about twitch chats are
that you're only looking at one at a
time and it's not like you're I mean
yeah maybe you have multiple tabs open
but I would expect that if someone has
multiple tabs open they would expect
that you know they're getting
proportional load as a result of that so
gist is if you have one chat that you
care about at a time what we can
actually do is put that chat ID or
rather the stream ID on one particular
chat server where everyone who cares
about the chat is connected to it via a
websocket we can just enforce this with
consistent hashing so these websockets
are going to allow us to both send and
receive messages in real time the fact
that we're using a persistent connection
means that we don't have to resend all
of these headers all the time and there
should in theory be lower overhead
additionally all of these messages will
be ordered which is also nice for
maintaining causal consistency through
that chat server uh whether we need to
persist all of these chat messages to
the database I imagine is kind of an
implementation detail if you want to I
guess you could I don't really know if
you necessarily need to it depends how
people like their recordings cool
however this also too breaks down what
if we have too many viewers for a given
stream or similarly just what if our
viewers are too uh geographically
distributed all over the world and now
you know there's just a ton of lag in
terms of getting these messages so what
can we actually do
instead what I propose instead here is
to do a different approach for the
popular streams where rather than
actually uh getting all of these
messages in real time there are a couple
of issues there right uh my client can
become overloaded because I'm just
receiving too many messages if there are
100,000 viewers that's a ton of incoming
data and number two that Central server
can become overloaded so what can we
actually do to fix this well well my
idea is basically let's send all of
these messages for that given stream to
one database and then every single few
seconds the client can just do a poll
right so you know I've taken in 10
seconds uh sorry I've taken in 10
messages and now 5 seconds later just
fetch me another 10 messages uh based on
the current Tim stamp uh and look back
for the last 10 messages from that
timestamp and then you might say oh well
you might miss some messages well I'll
say as a client side optimization when
you actually scroll up in the chat
window window you can then just load the
10 before that so we're basically lazily
loading everything instead of e uh
eagerly loading it so what do we
actually need to do this because what I
said is that all of our messages are
getting sent to one database and if this
is a particular po uh particularly
popular stream that is yet again going
to become a bottleneck so what are we
probably going to do here at least in my
opinion I think the move is probably
going to be
Cassandra the reason being twofold one
is that again we use LSM trees so in
memory wres to that buffer and then
number two is that we're using
leaderless replication So in theory
depending on the consistency mode that
we're using if we're not using Quorum
consistency for example because whatever
it's chat who needs it um you can just
basically go ahead and write to any
single one of these leaders and then you
know read from however many you want
down the line so Cassandra could be nice
and it'll perform anti-entropy in the
background for us to hopefully make
these reads a little bit better for our
clients and actually contain all the
information that we need another uh
thing that I did want to mention about
Cassandra is that because it is
leaderless and depending on the actual
consistency level that we use whether
it's Quorum or something like that we
probably aren't going to achieve causal
consistency here right it's possible
that um you know I write a message
someone replies to it and then someone
replies to that message and I only see
my own message and the third message and
I don't see the intermediary one because
it went to a different leader that being
said it's twitch chat do I really care
when there's 100,000 people you really
can't tend to follow the chat anyway
it's a complete mess and garbage and uh
as long as some chat messages are
showing up I think frankly that's better
than nothing uh but I'm open to arguing
about this one in the comments uh the
other thing to note is that because it's
Cassandra we have to basically choose a
partitioning key and a sorting key uh in
this case let's partition on stream ID
so that everything is being read from
the same partition and then sort on our
message Tim stamp cool um another thing
to note is because again this is a
leaderless uh database setup our message
Tim stamp uh is not going to be perfect
right all of our database leaders are
not going to be perfectly in sync and so
messages could technically be sent in
one order and then arrive to my client
out of order but again I don't really
care it's twitch chat there are this
many people uh it's going to be chaos
cool so the gist is now we can read all
of these messages at our own pace as
opposed to having to basically ingest
all of them and potentially overload our
client uh by using too much memory or
too much internet bandwidth trying to
fetch all of these messages
cool the last aspect of this is you know
how do we actually switch between the
two right when do I know uh that a
particular stream should start uh going
from using that uh websocket based chat
server to actually having the clients
PLL for chats I think the gist is the
chat server itself or the websocket
based one can you know constantly be
checking how many websockets it has and
if it surpasses some sort of threshold
go to zookeeper basically say hey for
stream id10 now all of a sudden this is
a popular stream so you should start
polling them all the clients can also
read from zookeeper uh put a watch on
that node for the stream that they care
about see that it's changed and then
start polling instead of trying to
listen through a
websocket cool the last aspect of this
thing is going to be going through the
formal diagram so let us go ahead and do
that so the first thing is that of
course we're going to have to have our
streamer the streamer via a load
balancer and some sort of consistent
hashing policy is going to connect to an
encoding server and this is where we're
sending our 1 second
chunks our encoding server is basically
going to turn these 1 second chunks into
multiple different resolutions right
it's going to encode them and so what's
it going to do with these you know three
to one chunks or something like that
well firstly it's got to put them in S3
right for recording sake and possibly
just for even loading them from a viewer
when they're not going through a cache
it's got to do the same thing in hbas to
record our chunk metadata the next
aspect of this is that we also are
potentially getting uh our cache data
populated and the way that we would do
that is by putting it either in our Rus
metadata cache or our CDN right so the
CDN is going to hold the static content
so that's what whatever would have been
in S3 and our reddest metadata cache is
going to hold our metadata data or our
just metadata jeez come on Jordan it's
late uh which is whatever is in hbas so
hopefully that all makes sense the last
two pieces of this are going to be the
actual ual chat which of course uh when
we have a viewer over here for unpopular
streams they're first going to go
through a load balancer which is going
to basically hit a chat server and the
chat server they're going to connect to
Via websocket and so would say another
viewer on that same small chat right
this way they can communicate with one
another however Beyond a point uh if
this stream gets too popular what
they're ultimately going to start doing
is both writing to and reading from this
guy over here which is our Cassandra
database which as we know is a leader
list database that we're going to
Partition by stream ID and sort all of
our messages by their timestamp well
guys I hope this makes sense I'm now
going to basically repack all of my
camera gear after having had to unpack
it uh because my flight got canceled so
I'm already on tilt and uh yeah hope you
all sleep well have a good night